C Chantal Hébert, Hélène Buzzei
etet Michel C. Auger, bonsoir.
C'C'est rare que je vous demande
sisi vous allez bien. Je ne
dedemande jamais ça.
- - Trop d'information.
- - Je vais vous dire la vérité,
jeje suis en train de lire votre
chchronique, Chantal, qui est
totoute chaude. Je n'aurais pase
tetemps de la finir. Les
frfrancophones dans ce pays aurt
drdroit à la fin de l'exercice à
trtrois rendez-vous importants :
leles entrevues de dimanche
dedernier, le débat demain et le
coconsortium de dimanche.
- - C'est vraiment pour faire de
l'l'information et de l'éducatin
popopulaire. C'est le genre de
susujet qui décolle, qu'ils
veveulent tous se mettre à genox
dedevant le Québec.
- - C'est le modèle particulier.
plplate-forme libérale dévoilée.
OnOn va écouter M. Trudeau.
JUJUSTIN TRUDEAU
chchef, Parti libéral l du Canaa
- - On est sur la bonne voie
paparce qu'on a été là pour
apappuyer p
leles petites entreprises,
popour appuyer les travailleurs,
popour investir dans la recherce
etet l'innovation. Et c'est
exexactement ce qu'on va continr
dede faire avec un plan
reresponsable, prudent et aussi
trtransparent. Les autres partis
nene sont pas en train de partar
leleurs chiffres, n'ont pas
papartagé leur projection.
AÀ part de dire qu'une pensée
mamagique que l'économie
vava croître à 3 % pour les
1010 prochaines années, ce qui e
s's'est jamais passé dans la vie
dede notre pays. Nous avons un
plplan concret et très ambitieu.
- - Je vous donne les points
rarapidement. pour faire face ea
pépénurie de main-d'oeuvre, on t
quque les garderies sont une
réréponse. Crédit aux aînés,
mamaintien au travail, pour aidr
lele maintien au travail des
pepersonnes plus âgées.
D'D'abord, est-ce que c'est le
gegenre d'annonce qui est
imimportant? Bien sûr qu'on
dédécortique tout ça, il faut le
fafaire. Les gens ne vont pas
alaller lire tous les détails de
totous.
- - Ils ne vont pas additionner
chacacun des chiffres. Ce que M.
TrTrudeau dit, c'est qu'il va
cocontinuer à dépenser pour sorr
lele pays de la situation
écéconomique difficile. En même
tetemps, on ne peut pas oublier
quque pour trois dollars de
dédépenses supplémentaires que e
gogouvernement propose, il y a
seseulement un dollar de revenus
susupplémentaires. À un moment
dodonné, il y a quelqu'un qui va
cocommencer à dire qu'on va avor
unun problème de déficit.
IlIl reste que du trois pour un
alalors qu'on a déjà dépensé
bebeaucoup durant la pandémie,
c'c'est beaucoup. C'est
popossiblement quelque chose qui
vava effrayer une partie de
L'L'Islet sera.
- - Ils vont aller se cacher ou?
PaParce que ce n'est pas Erin
O'O'Toole qui va leur dire ça ac
unun programme qui n'est pas
chchiffré beaucoup de dépenses.
QuQuelque part, le fait que les
coconservateurs n'arrivent pas
nénécessairement avec une plate-
foforme chiffrée, il y a beaucop
dede dépenses dans cette plate-
foforme, ça empêche Erin O'Toole
dede dire qu'il va y avoir
d'd'immense déficit. Et apportse
didire de régler le déficit en
didisant, ça le laisse un peu ss
didiscours. J'ai comme l'intuitn
ququ'il va y avoir autant : à
peperdre sur l'absence de chiffe
dede son programme électoral que
JuJustin Trudeau.
- - Nous somme dans une période
asassez surréaliste parce que
d'd'habitude en campagne
élélectorale, la raison pour
lalaquelle on peut voir les cads
fifinanciers, c'est qu'on regare
leles revenus et les dépenses, t
onon regarde si ça s'équilibre.
DeDepuis quelques temps, le
gogouvernement a totalement
rerenoncé à retrouver l'équilibe
bubudgétaire, a même renoncé à
reretrouver un ancrage fiscal.
LaLa surenchère est permise.
N'N'importe qui
pepeut promettre à peu près
n'n'importe quoi, ça ne fait
prpresque plus de différence.
C'C'est quand même une période
asassez surréaliste. Je pense qe
cecette plate-forme, c'est qu'ee
nonous révèle, c'est que ça nous
rarappelle à quel point le plan
ininitial du Parti libéral était
d'd'aller en élection au printes
totout de suite après le dépôt e
leleur budget qui contenait ausi
dedes dépenses pour 101 milliars
dede dollars. Le plan était de
fafaire campagne sur ses dépens.
IlIl y a eu la troisième vague t
onon a été obligé de remiser le
bubudget. Et nous sommes pris ac
unun budget qui est un peu de la
vivieille nouvelle et on est
obobligé de faire autre chose.
- - Vous avait mentionné que M.
O'O'Toole refuse de chiffrer sa
plplate-forme, de dire comment n
didisant il éliminerait les
dédéficits. On va l'écouter.
- - On a un plan pour
lele rétablissement du Canada
apaprès la pandémie.
- - Un plan chiffré?é?
- - Un plan avec un plan
d'd'équilibrer le budget au cous
dede la prochaine décennie.
OnOn assume notre plan
imimmédiatement pour le directer
paparlementaire du budget.
OnOn a un objectif d'une
crcroissance économique de 3 %
papar année. On va atteindre
nonos objectifs. Nous sommes
lele seul parti en faveur d'une
rerelance économique dans toutes
leles régions.
- - Il propose pas d'années
d'd'austérité, il dit qu'il n'y
auaura pas de compression.
IlIl veut rassurer. Il ne veut s
nonon plus être le champion de a
nonon dépense nécessairement.
- - Parce qu'il n'y a pas dans e
momoment un auditoire, je ne sus
papas convaincu qu'il en a la
plplupart du temps, mais il n'a
papas en ce moment un auditoire
vavaste pour ce genre de discou.
1010 ans, c'est la durée au
popouvoir généralement deux
paparties au Canada. Donc,
MoMonsieur autour a bien beau de
quque dans 10 ans il va avoir
éqéquilibré le budget... Ce qui
esest possible. Les libéraux die
ququ'ils vont réduire radicalemt
d'd'une année à l'autre. On se
reretrouve quand même dans une
sisituation où ça faut rapideme.
MaMais c'est facile de dire dans
1010 ans, parce que dans 10 ans,
sisi on élit Monsieur autour,
pepeut-être qu'en 2031, il aura
papassé.
- - Je veux parler du passeport
vavaccinal. Mais sur les financs
pupubliques, comment ça se joue?
- - Le problème de Monsieur au
O'O'Toole, c'est qu'il est aussi
dadans le club des lunettes ros.
AuAujourd'hui, statistiques Cana
dédécornait en contraction de
l'l'économie de 1,1 %. Sadique n
nene peut pas assurer la
crcroissance juste avec c des
dédépenses gouvernementales. Et
d'd'autre part, M. O'Toole, ces
lulunettes sont vraiment bien
teteintées parce qu'on ne peut s
àà ce moment-ci faire des
prprédictions comme ça.
- - Comment vous voyez la
dédémarcation entre les deux?
- - M. O'Toole dit qu'il ne fera
papas de coupure pour atteindre
soson objectif. Il faut mettre a
enen nuance. Il va quand même
anannuler certains programmes
imimportants des libéraux. Je
pepense notamment à celui sur ls
gagarderies. Il la dit en débute
cacampagne : on a cet objectif e
raramener ça à l'équilibre
bubudgétaire dans 10 ans, le
prprogramme des garderies, on na
papas les moyens. De dire qu'il
n'n'y a pas de coupure est une
chchose, mais de penser que tous
leles promesses libérales se
mamatérialisera sous M. O'Toole,
c'c'est une autre paire de
mamanches. Est-ce qu'il y a un
apappétit pour parler d'un peu
plplus d'équilibre budgétaire? e
nene suis pas tout à fait d'accd
avavec Chantal là-dessus. Je pee
ququ'il y a des gens qui
cocommencent beaucoup à s'en
prpréoccuper. On voit les
ququestions que le public nous
enenvoie. Et s'il faut en croire
ceces questions, un très grand
nonombre d'individus sont
prpréoccupés par l'équilibre
bubudgétaire. Il y a peut-être
plplus compense un appétit pourn
didiscours d'un peu plus de
cocontrôle budgétaire.
- - Passeport vaccinal en Ontar.
JeJe vous fais entendre Monsieur
FoFord. Il dit que dans le fond,
c'c'est à cause de Trudeau, il
auaurait dû en faire un.
- - Il dit au lieu de déclencher
unune élection inutile, il aurat
ddû fait un passeport vaccinal à
mama place.
- - Toutes les provinces
s's'attendaient à ce qu'il fasse
çaça. On a pas entendu François
LeLegault, qui ne passe pas son
totour généralement quand il vet
blblâmer M. Trudeau, dire la mêe
chchose. Les anglophones ont une
exexpression pour cette
dédéclaration, ils appellent ça
unune feuille de figues. La
fefeuille est tellement petite
ququ'elle ne couvre pas la
pepersonne qui est en train
d'd'essayer de faire une volte-
faface, ce qui est en train
d'd'arriver en Ontario. Je ne ss
papas convaincu que ça va passer
lala rampe. Les gens qui veulent
unun passeport vaccinal sont
nonombreux en Ontario est ils
n'n'ont pas tendance à être
coconservateurs. Et les
coconservateurs qui n'en voulait
papas ne vont pas être satisfais
papar cette réponse. M. Ford
cocommencent un peu à sortir de
leleur tanière avec les sondages
ququi montrent que ça va bien pr
ErErin O'Toole.
- - Il y a une autre expressionn
ananglais qui dit : the devil me
meme do it. je ne voulais pas le
fafaire, mais je suis obligé dee
fafaire. J'ai élargi un peu la
ququestion, il y a quelque chose
d'd'intéressant avec M. Trudeau
auaujourd'hui dans sa plate-fore
élélectorale qui va protéger les
ememployeurs et qui voudrait
ininstaurer la vaccination
obobligatoire, qui semble avoir
cecette idée de vouloir instaurr
lala vaccination obligatoire.
- - Pour faciliter, à tout le
momoins.
- - Si tout le monde embarquait
dadans le bateau, est-ce que ça
veveut dire que les personnes nn
vavaccinées n'auraient plus le
drdroit de travailler au Canada?
IlIl y a une question qui mérite
d'd'être posée.
- - Michel, avez-vous une
exexpression en anglais aussi?
- - Aujourd'hui, je n'en ai pas.
MaMais je note que c'est aussi
susurréaliste. Je ne voulais pas
enen faire un, mais je pensais e
TrTrudeau allait en faire un, ça
n'n'a pas de sens. Pour un
élélecteur ontarien moyen,
MoMonsieur Ford continu de
s's'enfoncer. Et c'est le
prproblème. Il est peut-être soi
dede sa tanière parce que Monsir
ouou Toul remonte dans les
inintentions de vote.
- - TVA présente demain son fac-
àà-face. Il y aura le débat la
sesemaine prochaine française et
ananglais. On voit que ça bouge.
RiRien n'est joué.
- - Les débats ont néanmoins
tetendance à renverser ou à
acaccélérer les tendances. Et
c'c'est pour ça que tout le mone
dedemain a besoin d'un bon déba.
CÇa ne va pas extraordinairement
bibien. Il y a du mot pour le Bc
ququébécois. Le N aider, peut-êe
quque c'est de la glace, mais
c'c'est de la glace mince. M.
TrTrudeau, on n'en parle même p.
EtEt M. O'Toole a besoin de gagr
dedes points au Québec.
- - M. Singh, ça va bien dans le
rereste du Canada mais au Québe,
leles carottes sont un peu cuits
popour lui. Ça va être intéresst
dede voir la performance de la
chchef du Parti vert et de M.
O'O'Toole.
- - Madame Paul n'est pas là
dedemain. Moi je parle des deux,
jeje parle de tous les débats.
- - Pour M. O'Toole, il est
tetellement script et jusqu'à m,
ilil a beaucoup de difficultés à
sosortir de ces lignes... Ça
popourrait être difficile pour i
auaux débats.
- - Se débat est important parce
quque M. O'Toole a une chance de
sese présenter aux Québécois,
paparce que les gens ne lele
coconnaissent pas vraiment. C'et
auaussi important au Canada
ananglais se débat. Parce que si
lele lendemain matin, c'est écrt
quque quelqu'un a gagné ce déba,
çaça fait réfléchir les autres.e
n'n'est pas vrai que les Canadis
ananglais n'ont aucun intérêt pr
cece qui se passe au Québec.
CeCes importants pas justes pour
l'l'auditoire québécois mais por
lele Canada anglais.
- - Ou dans le Toronto Star.
- - Ça ne sera pas moin